we usually do the final five at the end
hence the word final um but can I do it
with you now sure okay everybody the
final five
okay I've never done it in the middle of
the show but I just felt like that this
felt fitting um because um someone's
actually here to ask you the questions
take a look oh this is
interesting no Erica surprise Dana Queen
natifa to everyone else look we had so
much fun doing Living Single that I
think the world needs to share a little
bit of that so I'm here for final five
you ready what is one behind the scenes
moment that you will never
forget oh my
goodness well first of all thank you
it's been a while since I've seen her I
love her congratulation on The Equalizer
she's a mommy now everything
okay um behind the scenes moment I think
it's just when we used to be in our
dressing rooms we used to have so much
fun and we would undress in front of
each other and compare
breasts this is what I'm talking about
the smallest in there which is saying
something because they were some big
buonas going all around but uh and I
love that we had that sort of thing that
we really cheered each other on but we
also with our bodies we were women that
were considered bigger women on TV and
to actually go and have our first um uh
person at sauce in wardrobe go look at
that look at how they're sitting up oh
those those are fine and we gave
ourselves a lot of encouragement so yes
I remember that a lot a lot of body
positivity that is thank you you're the
best at this game like this is what
we're all this is you shocked me with
her oh good well yeah in a good way next
question then oh Lord how could you
describe
me in one
word well I'll describe her as she's
describes herself a queen
yay that's such a perfect answer okay
next question who obviously we rocked
some epic 9s fashion but what's one
Trend that you would actually like to
bring back that I'd like to bring back a
trend um you know what I always liked
Cazal glasses was a trend that the hip
hoppers made kind of made them look like
cartoon characters but I thought it was
funny and they should maybe bring that
back some of that it hasn't gone
anywhere but I like them I I I love it
so much um okay next question okay Erica
what is a weird talent that you have
that most people don't know
about well if people don't know about it
I probably don't want to S them but I
can act like I have a nose job here it
goes oh my
God that's it it's insane Bravo that
should give me another doctorate it's
insane it works can you do that one more
time I don't
[Applause]
even dead deut it's nut okay last
question from I got one
Queen what's the strangest dream you've
ever had wow well what bye easy oh bye
oh easy yeah easy easy e so to her I'm
Easy E we all call ourselves yeah I love
Easy E Yeah Easy E um well I had a dream
about um a wolf in my kitchen and I kept
trying to kill it cuz it was attacking
my dogs and I asked my boyfriend the
dream he was tossing me knives with
butter knife things that would slip
through my hands like no no finally a
sharp knife and I put it in the wolf and
the Wolf did like this and then
disappeared and I woke up so I was at uh
Woodstock and there was a dream book and
they said uh could be an employee or a
friend or something is stealing from you
and I thought who there's no way but
things kept moving around and then IID
asked her cuz she was pregnant I said
I'd love to see a picture of your baby
so she brought me a picture and it was a
Polaroid and it was her in my
clothes and that was the wolf in my
kitchen and that's the first time I knew
that the dream was coming from a
different dimension it was something
that I would never paid attention to
well that is wild again answer to these
questions you are like I know it's more
than you asked for y'all that's what we
want more than we asked for